but they're the boring ones let me tell
you about the interesting ones the
interesting ones are the ones that live
in the middle of galaxies which are
enormous they're very very massive are
these rare exotic things or are they
quite commonplace like trees
they're fairly common because i work in
galaxies and we now believe that at the
center of every galaxy is a supermassive
black hole we're talking about millions
of times the mass of the sun so the ones
that are made from stars they're
probably a few times the mass of the sun
maybe 10 times the mass of the sun now
we're talking ones that are maybe a
million times 10 million times 100
million times the mass of the sun and as
far as we know
pretty much every galaxy in the universe
has one of these massive black holes
look in it in its center the main thing
it sort of connects to is how big the
galaxy is and in probably in the sense
that you would expect which is if you've
got a big galaxy it tends to have a big
black hole in the middle of it if you've
got a wimpy little galaxy it tends to
have a small black hole in the middle of
it
the short answer is nobody really knows
well i think that's still a pretty open
question that that really
um takes us back to the very early
universe and the formation of the first
galaxies so what is it ever exceeding
the growth of these supermassive black
holes is happening a very very long time
ago so this is about how to produce a
seed black hole we think we understand
more or less how they grow by
eating material by
by accreting matter and growing forming
in the early universe is still open yeah
it could be the very first generation of
stars we believe are very massive there
could be several hundred solar masses
and
you could you could form uh you know a
black hole maybe a hundred several
hundred solar masses from those first
generation of these superstars
and they might for example quickly
gobble up the gas around them
and grow very quickly
or it could be that you have lots of
stellar mass more ordinary 10 20 50
solar mass black holes that quickly
merge together and i don't think that
that's very clear whether it's lots of
small things coming together or whether
you you create a fairly large seed all
at once that then grows and it's
particularly interesting when you
realize that we can see now
very powerful quasars very far back in
time the most distant quasar now known
is a redshift of 7.1 redshift 7.1 means
we're seeing this quasar very powerful
quasar about 700 800 million years after
the big bang so we're looking back you
know over 12 billion years back in time
it didn't have long to grow
and the black hole in the middle it must
be about a billion solar masses to
produce a power that we see so a billion
solar masses of material has grown
within a few hundred million years
and that's quite tight so
forming the black holes
growing them quickly enough just about
feasible in the model but it's an
interesting question as to how it
actually worked i mean you can kind of
see how they grow in that one of the
ways we know that galaxies grow is by
crashing into each other emerging to
form big galaxies and you can see that
in that process what's going to happen
well originally you had two galaxies
each with its own black hole they'll
merge now there's a process they called
dynamical friction which effectively if
you've got anything massive in a galaxy
it will over time kind of spiral into
the middle and end up in the middle so
what's going to happen is your two black
holes in this merge system will end up
spiraling down and merging in the center
of the galaxy
and actually astronomers are currently
very excited about that because that
merger between two black holes that last
few seconds as they merge together
produces a huge burst of these things
called gravitational waves we know that
galaxies do merge they do come together
under gravity and collide it's not
impossible that in doing so there are
two super massive black holes come
together but one of them gets kicked out
through tidal forces it's a wondrous
thing to think of a supermassive black
hole hurtling through intergalactic
space
um but probably very unlikely that you
know it would ever come our way but
professor surely the only way for a
supermassive black hole to grow
isn't just by eating other black holes
it could just eat all the stars around
the place indeed and so that process
goes on as well and in fact when we see
these incredibly bright things called
quasars and other types of active
galaxies where you've got a galaxy with
something incredibly bright going on in
the middle almost certainly the reason
why there's something incredibly bright
going on in the middle is because
material is falling into the vicinity of
that black hole and again once it falls
into the black hole you don't see it and
so actually that wouldn't make it bright
but these very energetic processes that
occur close to the black hole horizon
are very likely creating some of these
very energetic phenomena we see and that
will make the black hole grow as well so
it's kind of like the bustling crowd
waiting to fall in gives off a whole lot
of heat and energy something like that
yeah and because it's falling in from
such a long distance and because the
black hole is so dense it's got a long
way to fall so if you think if i drop an
apple onto the floor it's only going
that far and going bang but if i take
the same amount of mass in the earth and
squish it down into a really dense
object drop the apple from the same
height
it's got a lot further to fall it's
going to be going a lot faster by the
time it reaches the black hole so it's
converting that potential energy into
thermal and kinetic energy so it's
really transforming you know something
that's falling
into something that's very energetic the
trouble is that once it's snacked on
everything that happens to come within
reach of it that's it right because
actually things tend to stay on just the
orbits that they're on to start with and
so the time scale for any more food to
arrive is actually very long so indeed
what you say is true that a black hole
will grow kind of within its sphere of
influence it'll eat everything up but
once it's done that it's kind of run out
of things to eat and so actually at that
point it will probably
no longer be accreting and that's
probably why some galaxies are in this
state where we see a very bright nucleus
where they're clearly in these actively
eating phases where others others like
the milky way there's really not much
that much going on in the center of our
galaxy just because probably the black
hole is not eating anything very much at
the moment
does the supermassive black hole at the
center of the milky way have a name
sagittarius a star it tends to get
called um because it sort of coincides
with a radio source which was what was
originally given that name and it's only
subsequently we realized that's probably
where the black hole is that's actually
it is a source of radio waves it's
pretty quiet i mean you can see it blink
from time to time maybe it has a little
snack on something and suddenly there's
a little bit of brightness from there
but basically
the main reason we know there's a black
hole in the middle of the milky way
isn't by seeing the black hole it's
actually by seeing the stars around it
we've actually over over years a number
of astronomers have been following the
motions of stars and it looks like
there's a whole bunch of stars near the
middle of the galaxy which are whizzing
around at quite high speed which means
there's a pretty strong gravitational
field that's holding them there but
there's nothing much to see
and so there's you know several million
times the mass of the sun you can figure
out has to be the mass in order to
generate these kind of orbits but it's
not actually giving out much light and
so that's probably the strongest
evidence for one of these supermassive
black holes there is is that there's
clearly something very massive there
otherwise you wouldn't have these stars
following these orbits but actually it's
not doing anything other than being very
massive which is kind of the definition
of a black hole it's a lot of mass and
not much else so probably
although every galaxy has this
supermassive black hole they're not
always in an active phase they may go
through phases
or they may only switch on once in the
early part of the galaxy physically even
though it's a very very small fraction
of the size and mass of the galaxy
we think that the black hole itself
plays an important role in governing the
evolution of that galaxy black holes at
the center of galaxies can actually
drive material out which is a really
counterintuitive thing and that's
because material comes down towards the
black hole it has to lose angular
momentum it usually forms a disc that
disc gets really hot because the
material in it is is you know rubbing up
against each other and produces
radiation that radiation can drive a
wind that then blows material out of the
black hole so this
before it's actually got in so it's not
going to push the stars around nothing
but gravity can really do that but
there's a lot more to a galaxy than just
stars there's gas and dust all the raw
material for making more stars and if
you blow the gas out of the galaxy so if
you've got say a disc galaxy you got
black hole in the middle and you blow it
out this way
it means that that galax that gas is not
available to produce more stars for
example one of the things that we the
astronomers are very interested in is is
galaxies tend to form stars but some
galaxies stop forming stars and so we
need a mechanism a sort of feedback
mechanism that somehow stops a galaxy
from forming stars
and one of the things it could be is if
a whole bunch of material gets secreted
onto a galaxy that will tend to make it
make lots of stars but if that then
makes the nucleus very active so it
blows material out that can then
actually shut the process down and can
act as a kind of a a regulator a
feedback process
we're we're forming stars it's a normal
staffed spiral galaxy and at the moment
the black hole in the middle isn't doing
anything very much so in a few billion
years the andromeda galaxy is going to
come crashing into the milky way it
could be that's that would stir things
up to a create a sudden burst of style
formation but actually b maybe even fire
off the black hole in the middle of one
or the other or both of these systems to
actually shut down the star formation
process
galaxies can go through a number of
generations of these things so it could
well be in the past that the milky way
went through these active phases maybe
that slowed down or shut down star
formation or maybe it never quite got to
that point so it could well be that if
you if we could kind of wind the clock
back we would have seen the black hole
in the middle of the milky way doing
more dramatic things than it does now
but then we wouldn't have our gas well
there's more gas there's always more gas
arriving so eventually it will kind of
you may deplete it through one of these
events but then maybe more of it will
get accreted more material will fall in
so actually even galaxies which have
gone through the shutdown process they
can be rejuvenated and start forming
stars again interestingly though we have
seen because we've spent so long now
looking at this black hole
in our neighborhood in the center of our
galaxy we've actually seen not just the
stars orbiting around it but we've
occasionally seen things fall in it may
snack on a little gas cloud or something
and it does light up in that in that
event
i can generally describe them in terms
of classical theory so i can talk about
you know electromagnetic fields that you
know you're normally familiar with the
classical force of gravity that pulls
pulls me